this is EE 380 this is the last second
to the last uh of the
talks for uh spring uh 2023. uh our
speaker today is Charles Dahan he's uh
at the office of Science and Technology
policy uh in Washington DC and he is
responsible for
designing quantum computers and
coordinating the national quantum
initiative
uh quantum computers are uh thought some
by some could be like
uh well like Fusion it's uh you know
going to be the best thing in 50 years
and it will next year be the best thing
in 50 years but that's not true now
quantum computers are real things and
our uh
practical in some instances today and I
think we're going to have a major uh
interest in additional quantum computer
work because well
it's one of the things that we do uh
Charles
um thank you very much for coming and
I'm going to just leave the uh the the
channel open here for you all right well
then thank you Dennis
um I gave this seminar back when I was
starting my career so it's it's nice to
be to be back and years later yeah okay
so back to the scheduled program my name
is Charlie tahan I'm the assistant
director
for Quantum information science at ostp
I'm also director of the National Crime
coordination office I'm on detail from
the laboratory for physical sciences
which is a uh the research physics
division of NSA
um located at the University of Maryland
College Park I'd just like to start all
the talks I give with
this slide which says basically there's
many ways to contribute to your field
you know in my career I've done a lot of
different things I've worked in Academia
I've worked as a consultant at DARPA
um I've uh LED research teams in the
government have been a technical program
manager and now I'm doing policy uh in
the National Quantum coordination office
so there's many different ways to move
science forward and I just like to
highlight that for people maybe coming
from school and and haven't realized
that yet I'm happy to take any questions
at the end and about different pathways
it's been a big year for
um Quantum policy in the U.S uh
President Biden signed two
uh presidential directives back in May
which is pretty unusual it has never
happened before it probably won't happen
again the first was executive order to
create the national economy initiative
advisory committee as a presidential
committee to to advise him and Congress
and the leaders of the agencies on
the nqi programs
the second was the National Security
memorandum
which is very much like an executive
order
on the the risks of quantum computers in
moving the country to post crime
cryptography so I'm going to tell you a
little bit both about those things in
the in the whole
uh
policy behind the National Equipment
initiative today as well as give you an
example of
how one agency my agency is implementing
some of these aspects of the strategy
I'll just start off by saying my field
is code of computing that's primarily
where I've spent the last 20 years of my
research career this is my favorite
picture of the last year this is
President biding visiting IBM research
on a tour of New York and the various
Fabs up there
um of course it had to be copied from
somewhere you know this is a picture of
me
um I'm just being facetious copying the
president when I was visiting a fermilab
earlier in the year
okay let me just remind you why
Quantum information matters
if you think about all technology we use
today it's based on primarily it's based
on our understanding of how physical
devices work
we call
how matter behaves at the microscopic
level quantum mechanics those are the
rules that govern how very small things
behave
in our first foray into taking our
understanding of that and applying
technology resulted in things like
clocks
the transistor you know Imaging devices
like MRIs magnetic resonance imagers
you know with those physical devices
then we built abstractions
we developed information Theory you know
the zeros and ones the language that
lets us design operating systems and
compilers and programming languages
and all that has worked you know
tremendously well if you think about how
impactful information technology has
been on our lives
um
but
it's wrong you know the the information
theory that
really governs all the technology you
use now
um the idea of training machines and so
on
it works but it's not complete
and that realization you know which
really began in the 1980s that if we
really to design want to design
Information Technology based on how the
universe really works we really need to
incorporate quantum mechanics that
is what has led to this new field called
Quantum information science
it's a very crudely just to remind you
Quantum 1.0 you know the technologies
that were built off of the first 50
years of quantum mechanics you know
since it was discovered in the early
1900s
that technology is based on really a
couple simple facts about how the world
works you know one that matter is
quantized into atoms into photons into
electrons
and two that these these
systems these particles have discrete
energy levels
and from that you can design things like
lasers you can think about one electron
going through a transistor and so on and
that led to electronics photonics and
many other Technologies Cloud
information science is about taking the
second order effects of quantum
information Theory the stuff we've kind
of ignored over that first hundred years
almost 100 years or so
in trying to make better information
technology out of that so Quantum
superposition that a particle can be
in two places at the same time quantum
entanglement that particles can be
correlated over great distances and need
to be treated as a single object you
know Quantum measurements that when you
look at a Quantum object or measure it
it collapses to one of the basis States
or the classical states that it that it
that it's in a superposition of these
things can let you potentially design
new types of sensors new types of
computers and networks that allow you to
couple Those sensors in computers that's
really what Quantum information science
technology
is about trying to use those second
order properties
and it really is a foundational shift in
information technology I mean it is
something to be excited about because we
have a few examples where
we know or we extremely strongly suspect
you know believe that it will be
dramatic Quantum version of certain
technologies will be dramatically better
or different than the best thing you can
do classically so first you know just
for science
if you want to explore quantum mechanics
we know that you can't perfectly
simulate
um
multiple large Quantum systems past 50
or so qubits you know we can kind of
stretch it out
to 100 if you if you make a lot of
approximations but beyond that we just
can't do it on a classical computer so
if you had a quote here bigger than that
there's a lot of science likely that
we're going to learn
two you know the first killer app
cryptanalysis
this is Peter picture of Peter Shore it
was at Bell Labs at the time he came up
with an algorithm that could only run
under control computer that happens to
break you know the the dominant
mathematical hard problem that underlies
our public key cryptography system
so this is called Shores Quantum
algorithm we just we have done a lot of
work with that algorithm over the last
20 years and you know at Presence to the
art we think it requires around 10
million qubits
it's fairly high quality to
build a claw machine that large to break
they could break a public key
cryptography
so Crypt analysis and then chemistry
because
the universe operates by the rules of
quantum mechanics when it calculates the
properties of chemical or chemical
Dynamics or materials you know it's
using reality so if you could build a
simulator a digital simulator of quantum
a quantum computer
um there's a lot of evidence that if
it's big enough we can do things that we
just can't calculate classically and
there are many other things that are a
little bit more speculative but these
three alone you know are you know
concrete examples where the larger
computer is going to do things at a
classical Technologies can never do
and so there's reason for excitement
I'm going to start by telling you about
the national Quantum initiative and
what my job is and what we're doing at
ostp and across the agencies to
coordinate this activity
first
the first thing you understand is the
United States is a federal very Federal
system in terms of r d funding
we we operate in a kind of a cycle of
Congress uh
creating laws to Spur investments in
certain areas the president and the
Executive Office of the President all
the agencies within it including office
management budgets ostp now Security
Council
recommending what should be done what
kind of initiatives or or areas of
technology that we should the U.S should
invest in which our policy be and then
the agencies who actually implements
what the other two you know what what is
funded by by Congress and they have
their own missions each very different
they have their own models of funding
each very different
and that's kind of system together makes
the federal side of r d science
investment in the U.S and that sits
within the greater ecosystem of Industry
on the one hand in Academia and the
national and federal Labs on the other
which work together to actually Advance
research and developments and this is
very much true of quantum and there over
the years there have been a few National
level initiatives that congresses has
enacted
uh the latest of which is the artificial
intelligence
coordination uh activity
um before that was the quantum one
before that National anal technology
initiative
um climate change and so on
the national Quantum initiative Act
passed at the end of 2018.
it was really the culmination of two
decades of investment from federal
agencies and helping to create this new
field
um and you know
I think a reflection of a growing Indus
interest from industry and investments
from industry
to explore the potential
so Congress
um passed this act it was signed by the
president at the end of 2018 it did a
few things it created my office the
national Quorum coordination office
within ostp
the nqco is detailed is made up of
dtlees like myself from the federal
agencies that fund most of the quantum r
d in the US so NSF Department of energy
nist the National Institute of Standards
the technology Department of Defense
which is like a country in and of itself
it's got DARPA many different all the
service Labs have their own funding
agencies the intelligence Community
which has
IRP of the intelligence DARPA and LPS
and so on so the incusator is quite
unique we have four to five Quantum
physicists and computer scientists in
the in the White House you know working
to coordinate all the programs in the
nqi those programs consist of
uh National Quantum information science
research centers so doe was asked to
stand up five NSF was asked to send a
five
um in the dod in the IC stood up or
designated three in separate legislation
so we have 13 National Quantum
information science centers which are
brand new direct result of the nqi
roughly the base funding for r d
programs across all the agencies doubled
in the last few years which was a direct
result of nqi
uh nist was asked to help industry
launch a Quantum Economic Development
Consortium an industry Consortium for
Quantum that now has roughly 160
companies participating Plus
professional societies
um and uh you know some universities who
want to understand
the economic
roadmap for Quantum Technologies it
called for a pres an advisory committee
for the nqi and and so on so that's what
the legislation did
foreign
coordinated
is twofold one is through the
coordination office the other is through
subcommittees that are housed in the
white house so the National Science and
Technology Council forms interagency
subcommittees which then oversee the nqi
program so the quantum actually has two
subcommittees one led by the civilian
agency's doe NSF anist and the other
focusing on the economic and security
implications of quantum led by DOD NSA
and doe again because doe has a dual
dual mission space
so there's two subcommittees the
co-chairs of those
as legislated overseeing you know the
nqi programs but just remember it's the
agencies that implements
um r d funding in the U.S
okay uh one of the first things we did
as an interagency and this happened
before actually the the law was passed
let's write a strategy
so together we we went through kind of
the current status of nqi and of the
quantum information science ecosystem
and what would be
needed to enhance U.S leadership in
Quantum which is ultimately what's the
goal of the National Crime initiative is
and the result of that were six
high level policy thrusts you know take
a science first approach
given that this is still an emerging
technology
provide the key infrastructure needed to
solve the important problems you know
facing the field
uh invest and grow the quantum Workforce
because there's a dire need for experts
from industry and in the government
nurture the new industry that's being
created in this space as applications
are being looked for balance the
economic and natural security
implications because Quantum right from
the start had this dual nature because
of Shore's Quantum algorithm for
factoring and then six continue the
collaborate internationally because
Quantum has always been a global field
and the ideas have come uh really from
around the world since the beginning
over time over the last four years we've
augmented that strategy we've released a
Workforce strategy a few technical
focused strategies on the core on
networking and Quantum sensing which
help guide
um
investments from the agencies and
explain to Congress you know what are
the most important things that we should
do how should we prioritize what our
investments are
in the different Technologies
so with those six kind of pillars in
mind
to boil it down into you know what we
really mean by what we want to do you
know first and foremost get the science
right
so if you want to avoid when you're when
you're faced with a lot of choices and
Quantum is a very broad field you know
it spans sensors networks computers
enabling Technologies post Quantum
cryptographic schemes that are that are
classical
you know the first thing you want to do
is understand the problems that you need
to solve you know one of those problems
is what are the applications that that
would drive further Investments and then
within those applications what are the
the technical unknowns
um in the engineering kernels that need
to be jumped over to actually realize
them
so the quantum Frontiers reports
captures a lot of that's uh Knowledge
from the community the agencies ran
dozens of workshops in the first two
years of the nqi we put out a request
for information we gathered all
information and boiled
the Grand Challenge problems down to
eight areas
where we should you know direct funding
and then in the individual individual
um technology is networking sensing
they're each at very different levels of
maturity we already have examples of of
sensors like Quantum clocks that are in
the global positioning system or in you
know magnetic resonance imagers
and there are others that are in the lab
now that we could bring over the finish
line for biomedical applications and so
on if we we you know apply ourselves and
increase that level of funding
networking is very different you know
we're still trying to understand what is
the benefit of building a large quantum
network
how big should it be what would you use
it for
um and so there you want to focus your
your investment more on solving those
problems rather than trying to bring
things to Market before you really
understand
why we're doing it
enhancing competitiveness is the second
thing so how do we both move quickly
enable our companies in our scientists
who
answer these hard problems as fast as
possible while at the same time
protecting our investments and if you
follow the news lately there's there's a
lot of debate over
how do you protect
our intellectual property in a world
where maybe it's not as easy as it was
50 60 years ago
um
so in that vein we try to listen to the
community
a year ago we had a little bit over a
year ago we had
most of the quantum companies come to
the White House and and tell talk to us
about what they're worried about
what expert controls could do to their
you know business their their research
Investments
our talent issues around talents and
visas impacting their ability to execute
their research and development plans
we also are assigned tasks from Congress
Congress asked us to do a research
security assessment of all the programs
across the government to to make
recommendations around expert controls
to various agencies so getting this
balance right is is a big part of what
we do
um and and uh it's important to
uh making sure that frankly that the U.S
benefits from the Investments were that
the taxpayers are making in this field
and the third thing is enabling our
people so if we believe that this is
going to create a whole bunch of new
jobs it already is to some extent if we
believe that technology is going to be
transformative Like Pat the information
technology revolution has then we need
to ensure that our our people are
educated
that we're attracting people from around
the world to work here and that you know
as many Americans as possible can
benefit from that investment so we do
that in a number of ways uh we we
encourage and work with the agencies to
invest in Workforce Development programs
so fellowships uh internships research
experiences
we created a National q12 Education
partnership together with the National
Science Foundation this is a
primarily industry-led organization that
is committed to bringing you know
curricula around Quantum to all grade
levels and to making uh for example
quality computers accessible to high
school students so that they can be
trained to participate we we brought the
U.S fulfill into World Quantum day uh
two years ago we said well
there's this Grassroots effort going on
to you know basically do Outreach for
work wanted and we said we're going to
be a part of that so we've launched a
couple of videos which you can find on
our website
um to a lot of other be proud um modules
to around 300 schools this past April
14th to teach give people a sense of
what Quantum is and um you kind of the
the potential of it
at the end of the day you know the most
important question I get is well with
all this investment what are what's
going to come out of it you know what
are they going to be the tangible things
that are technologies that are going to
benefit uh Americans
I already mentioned GPS as a kind of 1.0
Quantum 1.0 example
I mentioned Photon concuputing as a
longer term
uh we strongly believe that this will be
impactful
to uh to research and development of
drugs and other things but there are
many other questions we still need to
solve you know if you could entangle or
make a quantum network of sensors does
that make them better you know there's
still there's still some research to do
there to prove that to be true if we
know that there are new types of sensors
you can build based on Quantum
information properties
but how much better are they than the
best classical alternative and when does
that crossover happen and how much work
engineering work do we need to do to
make that an economically viable
transition to make so these are the
kinds of questions that we have to
continually ask what are the impact of
quantum Technologies
and how do we show that impact
especially you know as we look forward
to the next five years of the nqr
you know just as an example I mentioned
Quantum Computing you know there are
many different proposed algorithms that
a pro computer could be useful for but
How likely they are and how economically
or scientifically valuable they are is
still an open question because frankly
we don't have very big machines yet you
know our machines are sort of at the 100
qubit
noisy level
and so if you're going to make a you
know the perfect graph to show a senior
leader it'd be something like this this
is just a cartoon don't believe anything
that's on here but we know at the bottom
on the left side
that quality Peters passed a certain
point are going to be extremely
interesting to scientists they're going
to enable scientific discovery we've
done a work on a lot of work in
applications like cryptography but
there's still a lot of work in the
Middle where we have relatively low
confidence
about how good that these are really
really be and it's kind of analogous to
deep learning proposals of the 80s and
90s where until you've had computers
to test them on it was really hard to
prove that these algorithms would be any
any good
that brings me to Quantum computing
in the risk side which has to balance
this optimism side
right so we we know or everything that
we know about physics and information
science tells us that
if a quantum computer on sufficient size
and scale existed
it could break the encryption protocols
we use today you know to protect our
financial transactions protect our NASA
security networks
so because the government has to be
conservative has to we we typically had
to protect information for example that
the president the president's phone or
secure
nuclear codes and so on we need to
protect the information for 25 years at
minimum if not longer
so government crypto systems have to be
very
um long-lived and conservative and it's
similar for health and finance so
because of that and because the timeline
even though Punk computers might be far
away and hard to build because of that
decade-long
um timeline
we decided and and after discussing with
uh many of the agencies who are leading
the new standards for post Quantum or
Quantum resistance photography that we
really had to urge the movement of the
whole nation to to Quantum resistant
cryptography
that resulted in NSM 10 which really had
three parts you know the second part
which is prioritize this uh deployment
of quantum resistant cryptography but
the first part was
backstopping
our original goal in the aqi of to
maintain
leadership in this technology we need to
double down on our investments in r d we
need to increase our investments in
Workforce Development and Outreach and
we need to increase our Partnerships
with industry and in our allies and
foreign partners
and the third part was
in between this time you know because
even if we do everything perfectly it's
going to take a decade or more to
upgrade our cryptographic systems we
still have to invest we need to protect
our investments
um our company's Investments are our
government investments in the technology
so that's not used against us
okay
um
I mentioned a little bit uh
International cooperation is one of our
pillars
we've done a lot over the last few years
to increase the connections we have with
with our our friends and allies
we have 10 bilateral clone cooperation
statements now we've hosted numerous
International dialogues really focused
on these areas of joint interest how do
we create a new
stem Workforce for these new industries
of the future how do we protect our
investments multilaterally so we don't
slow anybody down in our network but we
can you know move forward in a safe
research environment
um
and three you know what are the core
values that we want to maintain as as we
create these new fields
the first thing we did was launch the
entanglement exchange you can go to
entanglementexchange.org and see
a link to each country who are
participating
it's basically a Clearinghouse for
opportunities for for students post-docs
professors to go back and forth you know
we definitely want to encourage this
across
um training I mean I myself did my
postdoc in England and Australia and
Japan
so that was an amazing you know that was
an amazing experience that has helped me
now 20 years later uh we want to
encourage and promote that and this is
our first step
um as a as a body of 13 countries now
there's 12 at the time
to to move increase our our cooperation
in space
let me just end this part
um with
what's going on in Congress the other
huge thing that happened this year
that's relevant to Quantum policy wise
was the chips and science act so the
chips Acts appropriated or funded about
50 billion dollars plus for
uh onshore manufacturing of microtronics
of that about 10 billion or 11 billion
is assigned to r d a new National
simulator Technology Center Advanced
packaging centers the dod Commons
you know as an emerging technology
Quantum you know very much fits within
that uh definition of of new
microatronics technology so that that's
a great opportunity for
for
um
investment in infrastructure and
capabilities that will ultimately help
this field
the science act portion which has not
been fully funded yet
um had some specific bylines augmenting
the national Forum initiative as
originally passed it it
authorized a new program to look for
applications Called Quest and authorized
the quantum networking infrastructure
program at du At Doe I asked NSF to make
a long-term
Quantum K-12 pilot program so these are
very positive enhancements of the nqi
that we hope to to see funded in the
coming years
finally
as part of the nqi advisory committee
um we Mets and actually it's co-chaired
by your own Stanford's own cam Mohler
um thanks thank you Stanford for that we
met back in May and delivered our first
draft recommendations
because the big thing that's going on
with the nqi is approaching five years
and had five years Congress must
reauthorize the national Quantum
initiative so the the advisory committee
has spent the last six months developing
recommendations for enhancing it and and
you can find that
at first meeting results up online and
we hope to have the report out soon
so that's the first part of my talk
which is the policy part the next part
is going to be talking about a deep dive
into a specific agency and actually one
of the national Quantum centers but
maybe I can answer any questions now if
there if there are or we can wait till
the end
okay
I'm going to transition and just
transition by saying Quantum is more
than quantum physics
uh you might you know look at everything
that's gone on corporate Mission science
this is just a bunch of physicists right
but that's not true if you think about
what it takes to build a quantum
computer or a
entangled Chrome sensor system
it's a lot of engineering computer
science electric engineering Asic design
you know Material Science
you name it you need it to build these
new computers and I think it's very
representative of the future which is
going to be a very heterogeneous uh
Computing uh
ecosystem right if you look at what's
going on with AI
neuromorphic Hardware architectures you
know all these things are going to be
very different from what we had in the
past and it will require a lot of
different skill sets and they're all
actually very similar skill sets
anything we invest in quantum
you know in terms of building the things
you need to build these systems is going
to benefit other things like autonomy
and Ai and so on
okay so this brings me to the last part
of my talk
which is LPS my home agency laboratory
physical sciences was started after
World War II at the University of
Maryland College Park it's a joint
research lab between the University of
Maryland and the National Security
Agency it's actually the physics
research arm of the NSA and it was
decided back then that you know if the
government wants to know what's
happening in Information Technology it
really needs to work
quote unquote outside the fence needed
to work
um with the top academic researchers
with industry and they needed to recruit
scientists and Engineers who were
working at that level and so they could
come back and be consultants and say
Well when asked like when is the Chrome
computer going to happen is it going to
happen is this a real thing or not that
you would have somebody within the
government who really knew what they
were talking about at the end of the day
that's the mission of LPS
so we have a group of scientists here
roughly
150 200 it fluctuates focus on various
aspects of Information Technology
Computing
networks sensing
in the quantum Computing space we
actually have a quite a long history of
helping to create this field uh very
quickly after Shores algorithm was
published in 93 94.
uh this is well before my time and even
before you know I started my graduate
school
2000.
um LPS was funding workshops to try to
answer these basic questions is Quant
Computing even a real thing it's even
physically possible to build such a
machine
and come 2000
um
they were confident enough to start
making both internal and external
Investments so they sort of the internal
research group here so we have a number
of research groups with students in
postdocs
um from the University of Maryland
working on aspects of of qubit
technology and it's sort of LPS sort of
the major external sponsor research
program working with the Army research
office
this was just out of necessity if you
think back to the beginning of the
computer science of the computer
Revolution before the vacuum tube or you
know in that transition from the vacuum
to to solid state transistors
very much we're in that
mode then and arguably still in that
mode where there were many many
different Technologies proposed as
physical realizations
of this abstract thing called a quantum
computer so you really had to fund a lot
of different groups to try to explore
what could make sense and what could not
make sense
so what that's what the sponsor research
program does it's grown even since I
made this slide we have roughly 100
principal investigators across many
different institutions around the world
focus on different Technologies
different qubit Technologies semi Vector
based superunking based Atomic molecular
and ion Optical based qubits really
trying to answer these questions like
are what are the fundamental limits of
devices that might realize a quantum
computer and
um where are we on this kind of
trajectory of something that might be
one day useful
the internal research is very similar
it's smaller and more focused on again
what are the hard problems that need to
be solved that could
you know disrupt the present
approaches to Cuba Technologies it would
have Material Science issues that need
to be solved to make them uh scalable
and it comes down to how we think about
the quantum challenge you know at the
end of the day
we want to answer the question is there
a system that you can build
that could run an algorithm like
Shores algorithm or a quantum chemistry
solver
the best
resource estimates we know now
indicate that you probably need a
machine that could operate 10 to the 14
or more operations
in a with a probability of success big
enough that you'll get an answer
sometime you know the correct answer
sometime
and you have to match that logical error
rate you need which is something like 10
to the minus 12 10 to minus 14 per
operation
to the reality of devices and the
reality of the devices today is that the
error rates per operation are roughly
one percent or 0.1 percent so three
nines fidelity
we're talking about 10 orders of
magnitude difference between the
physical devices and what's needed
the gap for the the thing that bridges
that is error correction Quantum error
correction
um also proposed by Peter Shore and
others which makes it at least
conceptually possible
to build large-scale machines at the
cost of many many many more qubits so
you might need
a few thousand logical qubits to such
one of these algorithms but that becomes
Millions
or or larger when you include order
correction depending on the error rate
you need at least that today's their
earnings
so I'll just give you a couple examples
if you're not you know
Aficionado of this field one of the most
popular approaches are superintend
qubits uh these are pursued by companies
like Google
Amazon rigetti IBM
uh I think of them as little washers I
mean this is not completely accurate but
if you take a a little a metal washer
made out of aluminum and you make it
cold
it's a super connector so if you start
current going in one direction it'll
just keep going forever if you keep it
cold
it's lossless right and you can call
that zero you can call counterclockwise
one and because it's a quantum
mechanical system it can have electrons
going left and right at the same time
from that you can make a qubits and then
you can design two cubic Gates one of
the most popular cubits today is called
the transmog qubit it's got nice
properties for
noise so they can it can it's very
robust you make it and it works but at
the end of the day it's it's a washer
you might think of it as an artificial
atom with energy levels so you can call
011 and so on so these are just a little
bit dated now but these are the 50 to
100 Cubit systems that you might read in
the news that people are putting
together
another approach or
seminator qubits which are most
analogous to mosfets or the Silicon
transistors that's
are in your computer here we take that
transistor down to the quantum limits
very cold
one single electron and instead of using
the charge as the information carrier we
use a spin you know spin could be up it
can be down that's your qubit because
it's called a mechanical you can be in a
superposition
and operations happen sort of like an
abacus you bring the electrons together
because they're fermions they interact
with each other in a unique way which
can create entanglement once you can
build a quantum computer that way this
is harder to make you have to make them
much smarter smaller right from the
beginning they're roughly a thousand at
least times smaller maybe ten thousand
we have six dot systems now and a few
groups after really
two decades of Investments but they're
now starting to to show that you can
also do Quantum computation this way and
there are many other approaches that I'm
not going to mention plutonic iron traps
the most important thing to realize
though is that it's not about the qubit
it's about building a chrome computer if
you think about what's needed to build a
quantum computer there are many
different uh layers there's the qubits
they need to be good meaning they last
as long long enough to do error
correction they have low error rates to
do Gates
that often means hard Material Science
problems virtually every qubit it means
my heart ritual science problems need to
be solved the second biggest thing
is interconnect qubits are analog
systems at the end of the day they're
Analog Devices to control them you need
very precise pulses
that means that every qubit needs to
have roughly its own wire some qubits
need 10 wires
which means that if you need a million
qubits you need millions of wires which
is dramatically different than anything
really we've built in Computing to this
this state to the game
so both those things qubits and
interconnect they have to be in an
environment
that's enables the quantumness typically
very cold 20 Milli Kelvin or so or
vacuum for iron traps
um in all the classical control
Electronics which is against the yard
because their analog has to be within
that envelope as well so this is what
makes the a holistic problem where it
often making one level of the stack easy
makes other layers harder right
and the greatest example I can give is
you know a modern processor if you look
at the Apple M1 which is roughly 10
billion or so transistors
um what makes this even possible what
made it easy over the last 60 70 years
of investment right the things that made
it possible are one
digital electronics that
you don't have to set exactly as perfect
a voltage level for each transistor you
just say well if it's higher than this
it's zero if it's higher lower than that
it's one
that makes the individual device is
robust
and two incredibly high must ratios so
if you look at the back side of the Chip
and you try to count you get roughly 3
000 wires coming out of this
computer chip that has 16 billion
transistors you know that's
fundamentally different from a quantum
computer where we think you're going to
need an order the same number of
transistors of lasers or wires or
whatever it is that controls them
so that makes that's a really really big
problem that will need to be solved if
these things are going to scale up
so that leads us so that's sort of the
nature of the problem and why we exist
you know this is the things we think
about in terms of the qubits technology
and that led us at the beginning of the
nqi to propose a new Research Center one
of the the national Quantum research
centers focused on advancing qubits to
solve some of these problems and we call
that the cubic Laboratory
so the Cleveland laboratory and remember
what I said the agencies Implement right
so the national strategy we wrote
together
um LPS said well we'll take this parts
of it on you know we will start a
Foundry for qubits to give to research
groups across the country and we will um
on behalf of the intelligence Community
create a center with three real goals
the first we'll continue to pursue our
fundamental research in new types of
qubits you know answering the are there
new materials that could uh
short-circuit progress in this area so
that meant physically doubling the
number of labs and infrastructure here
at LPS
um we also said well
help build the quantum Workforce because
as new agencies came into the quantum
field like the form of energy through
the nqi as new companies uh started
investing very large amounts of money
we're all fighting for talent and really
the only solution is to grow the pool
for everybody so we launched uh many new
Fellowship programs across the country
lots of new Partnerships with MIT UCLA
Maryland other other universities to
help create
um accelerated learning pipelines so
that we will have more people trained in
this area and then third is
we were going to come up with a new way
for the federal government and academics
and Industry to work together and that's
the collaboratory part
so we created a new model for for
interaction you know whereas DARPA NSF
will in lps2 will put out a call
typically and say hey we want to know if
you can make four qubits with two nines
Fidelity give us your ideas and then
we'll get we'll fund you to do it
that's the typical funding model
we said no we're not going to do that we
want to work together with you on the
problems we think that if we could solve
them would you know really transform the
field so don't come to us with your
Solutions come to us with your problems
so what we did is we put out problems
saying here are the things we care about
um do you want to help us work together
to form a research plan to try to solve
them
we put out six
kind of mission problems uh research to
us that we're looking for people to rely
on I'll give you a couple examples one
is
how can you make spin Cupids faster it
typically takes
five to ten years of investment in a
research group at a university to even
make qubits that start to work in the
Springfield land because they're so
small and they require so much
lithography so how can we make them
faster that could really transform the
field in terms of speeding up the
physics answers we can solve
um others include
can we make super nothing qubits that
are much smaller because they're made
epithetically perfectly crystalline and
compatible with CMOS electronics that if
you make them much easier to scale these
are really hard problems that we didn't
know the answer to right but this
motivated
Suburban project so here's an example of
one way you can make spin cubits fast
you can you could actually make flip
chips instead of making a
symmetric quantum dot chip
the traditional way which is layer by
layer where you have to solve all the
Material Science and process problems at
the beginning if you can make two chips
one where the gate gates are defined and
the other where you want to induce the
quantum dot qubit and then put them
together
maybe you can explore different
materials much faster so this is one of
our research thrusts
here's another one where if you can
instead of making this very large trans
Bond Cupid which is typically tens of
microns
uh longer or bigger if you could do it
epitaxial you can make a parallel plate
capacitor instead of a
planar transistor up a capacitor
you can make it a hundred times a
thousand times smaller but we don't know
what materials related let us do that we
have some ideas and we don't know what
the performance will be
but we know that if you could make it at
protection it's likely to have as good
or better performance even though it's a
thousand times smaller so that's one of
the the projects that we're working on
um that's it I'm not going to give you
any more technical stuff but happy to
answer any questions I'll just say that
the lqc is still growing we
intentionally sort of small another
thing we've done in support of the nqi
is is create a Foundry program where
we're working with Intel
um Lincoln Labs make superintend qubits
and hrl to make qubits that we can give
to our partner
academic research groups to help them
get get going faster you know if we want
to democratize the field of growth
Computing if we want to explore new
types of qubits quicker
we can't afford for every Professor to
have to go out and buy five million
dollars of Fab equipment so here we can
just give them some qubits that work and
let them explore their design ideas and
control ideas
and not have to do all that other stuff
right
you know we're hoping that we'll
actually
make us help us explore the phase space
of possible qubit types much quicker
so that's it I hope that was useful to
you I'm happy to answer any any any
questions about either the National
Crime initiative or LPS
so uh we have um uh been looking for
quite a while now into the uh the AI uh
large language model things and you know
the um the thought is since the creating
the original
collected information processed of all
human thought into a little lump uh is a
major computational effort uh that a
quantum computer would be a would be a
perfect thing and
um is that something where you're you're
you're you're sort of working your way
into or not I would say um people are
definitely doing research into
um
uh Quantum artificial intelligence
Quantum machine learning but there are
significant caveats uh to what's is
currently thought possible you know and
it's hard it comes back to what I
originally said which is these are
heuristic algorithms
which you can't prove one way or another
are better so until you have a computer
big enough to try to test out some of
these Quantum algorithms uh you could
only kind of poke at what you think may
or may not be
possible with that said there's a lot of
evidence
towards a negative result that quantum
computers aren't great at big data
problems like classical MP complete
programs that problems those are not
what cloud computers are good for
um
however on Quantum data it may be that
Quantum machine learning algorithms do
provide a large Advantage so if you have
a sensor Network bringing a whole bunch
of quantum data that you could you could
see some real separation but the reality
is we don't know yet the the
we need the test we need to test it
there are some algorithms that
potentially could provide speed up on
gradient descents or other classical
tasks that make up
um what happens in in the back
propagation and neural networks but
again
the real question is how big are those
speed ups are they just
so-called squared of N speed UPS versus
the exponential speed up of Shores
algorithm or some of the chemistry
algorithms and is it worth it given that
quantum computers are actually quite
slow
and when you add error correction and
everything you need to do to make them
they're very slow and they're not very
good at handling a lot of data in and
out
um if you think about shorter's
algorithm you give it a number and you
know end days or months later you'll get
two numbers out right so this very low i
o
um
so we the answer is we don't know
there's a lot of algorithms a lot of
proposed things for various aspects but
until we can test it
um it doesn't look good
but we're all optimistic especially for
on the quantum machine learning
chemistry kind of quantum data aspect of
it
yep
um one of the um one of the proposals of
course was use quantum computers to
simulate Quantum systems and we thought
substantial progress has been made there
yeah absolutely
um the only problem is that a lot of
work has been done on the classical side
too over the last hundred years you know
chemists are really good you know and
and people using uh classical high
performance computers are really good
because they have all these tricks and
if you look at how nature you know that
this what happens in in the natural
systems like many body systems or
various materials
a lot of times there's some inherent
symmetry or there's low levels of
entanglement which makes
classical tricks
like tensor networks and others work
really pretty well for a lot of problems
that we care about as humans so when
you're trying to beat
the best classical algorithm which has
had you know 50 100 years of work done
on it no it's hard it's hard as a
newcomer and you see that you saw this
with CMOS too like CMOS rolled over
every other
potential you know replacement because
they just kept moving along so quickly
um so that that's the problem you know
so we expect
hopefully soon
that as you get to
hundreds thousands of qubits which are
good enough Fidelity that you just can't
simulate it classically no matter how
hard you try
that there will be problems that we can
solve in chemistry at least very
scientifically interesting now whether
they'll be interesting for economic uses
we don't know yet
we don't we may need a much bigger
computer and that's really the Crux of
the big the big question for Quantum
Computing in the next five years is are
there going to be some applications that
really Drive
investment
in the near term or or are we going to
have to wait till to fall tolerate on
computing
okay
great
anyone else
and I would like to ask about ethical
and societal implications associated
with the advancements of quantum
information science and how a research
addressing these concerns because as it
also was covered slightly in this
presentation there is a concern for data
data privacy and security
so since quantum computer has the
potential to break current encryption
methods
so as well as others so what are the
societal implications that we can
already start working on now
in order to prevent
um misuse of quantum technology later
sure you know in some ways I'm very
fortunate that quantum
isn't very different in many respects in
this in the ethics ethics side of the
world like uh artificial intelligence
let's say quantum computers are relevant
to artificial intelligence well that
falls within AI ethics you know
cryptology quantum computers may be very
good at cryptology so that we know how
to deal with cryptology and it's a great
example of potential societal impact
because
you know when I talk about economically
useful applications for a quantum
computer it's chemistry designing new
drugs Material Science
but a really great driver if you were
unethical would be to build a quantum
computer and steal everybody else's
money in IP right so we do take that
very seriously and that was the reason
we did NSM 10 which is really to direct
the federal agencies to create a
timeline for moving
um the nation really for starting with
the federal government but working with
a Private Industry to upgrade
cryptographic systems so that they're
Quantum resistant now we have some time
uh there's two parts to cryptography
there's the authentication piece you
know the
um
signatures uh that's you really don't
need to solve until you have a chrome
computer out there you're worried about
but the save and decrypt later problem
is real you know if people can save uh
files that are encrypted now and wait
for a quantum computer to exist to
decrypt them so that motivates us to
move as quickly as possible to to deploy
Quantum resistant cryptography and in
that venue nist has been running an
international competition for the last
few years to create a new suite of
algorithms and these algorithms are
completely classical you don't need
Quantum fancy Quantum technology to
implement them it's just a classical
protocol
but they are harder to implement than
RSA which means that there'll be likely
needs need to be new type new routers
new hardware
that needs to be bought to upgrade it so
that will cost money and will be hard
and that's why we have to work with the
whole world to move that forward and I
would say that's the biggest risk of
quantum technology
sensors are another application like
Precision navigation and time keeping
but again we have
Frameworks for how to deal with sensors
uh we typically
focus on the application like a sensor
that's this good we need to protect
because it could be used for
steering missiles or whatever and it
doesn't really matter what the
technology is that
is based on that sensor right it could
be Quantum it could be classical so we
have we have methodologies to deal with
that so I think you're right that the
Crypt piece is the most important piece
and that's why we've been focusing on it
thank you
uh mark
so you've talked a lot about
um computing
um you know half the world thinks that
everything is a computer the other half
the world thinks everything is
Communications
um what about the half the world that
thinks that everything is Communications
have you been doing any work with
entanglement and communication systems
yeah so I divided up into kind of three
computer sensors which I've already
talked about
and networks which I haven't talked
about so thank you for bringing it up
actually the first
um
after we wrote the full strategy the
first Focus strategy we worked on was
quantum networking because it really is
in many respects the most immature of
our understanding and kind of our belief
is or the most immature in that area
even though like the first
proposed application really that got
traction for Quantum anything was bb-84
you know Quantum key distribution
but you know since that time we've
learned a lot of things we've learned
that
Quantum resistant cryptography
that's classically based seems to be
resistant you can come up with
algorithms the resistance on computer so
you don't necessarily need quote key
distribution or Quantum versions of
communication to do secure
Communications so that's motivated the
government to pursue that route as the
dominant way to protect information that
doesn't mean we don't need to understand
the implications of networking and
certainly
uh if you could distribute entanglements
easily
across long distances you can do some
amazing stuff you can
make two quantum computers effectively a
much bigger quantum computer you can't
do that with classical communication
right you can entangle Quantum sensors
we kind of don't know yet how if it's
worth it and that's one of the real
questions but we know that you do get an
improvement when you when you Quantum
entangle many sensors there are
proposals out there for creating long
Baseline telescopes if you had again
really fast really easy
entanglement distribution you could you
could link up to classical telescopes
together
to make a much bigger Baseline telescope
which would be tremendously cool
but
I think this is the most important thing
to know is that building such a network
is probably just as or harder than
building a large phone computer
right so
where we are and this is really really a
debate within the interagency and it's
really all codified in this Quantum
networking strategy you can find on
quantum.gov is you know how do we
prioritize
that potential promise versus the
unknowns like what would you use it for
and you know first and foremost we need
to unders we need to find the
applications that would justify that so
the main recommendation there was to
build Quantum networks but build small
ones that you could use to find kind of
test out the applications and the limits
of the technology because the big
difference and I think this is missed
sometimes between the Quantum Internet
and the internet
is that we already have an internet you
know like you know if you want to run a
code on a quantum computer you can log
in to IBM or Azure or AWS and run a
quantum computer simulation you don't
need
the Quantum Internet to do that you need
a Quantum Internet to do these very
specific things
um which we don't
we don't know how much they're worth yet
but just the pursuit of doing that
means making components that let you
transduce
different types of qubits with high
fidelity
and those those things are going to be
very useful for a lot of different
fields for sensors for hooking up
computers even in a lan within your
within your basement right
um we're going to need those no matter
what so basically the two main
recommendations from the interagency
group were focus on the core components
and build small test beds to find
applications and that's where we are at
a federal government level
thank you
anybody else
well thank you very much Charles thank
you appreciate it uh it's uh it's uh uh
from my perspective a guided tour of
alphabet soup of the federal government
is always very helpful
we have a very unique system it's very
robust right in many ways
also inscrutable if in other ways it
should period And I think that um I
think that the work that you're doing is
very very helpful and I think it's in
the long run going to be a
a great success for us uh whatever the
answer you you you can group comes up
with or the group comes up with uh it's
going to be very useful
and if we weren't doing this we would be
just in a position of not doing what's
going on it's impressive
anyhow thank you very much and thank you
the audience here